when they first invented sailboats they
were scared to ride them too far for
fear that they might fall off the end of
the world because the belief was that
the world was
flat then we developed enough uh
understanding to come to the belief that
the world is Round And as such you
cannot fall off the end of Earth I
wouldn't call I would call The Flat
Earth a belief and the round earth a
fact
okay you heard it here first fol can can
we can we use proper terms here all
right it's not that we believe Earth is
a
feere okay
so you you will be healed if you believe
you have evidence you don't you no
longer need to invoke the word believe
okay we learn that the world is Round
And as such you cannot fall off the end
of it